But we don't have one of these that fits in these question marks. This doesn't exist. There's not a good language today that I can fit into those question marks that takes this successor language approach in order to be a compelling option for current SQLs Plus users. And a few of us thought, this is really too interesting
但我们没有一个能完美嵌入这些问号的选项。这并不存在。当今没有一种优秀的语言能契合那些问号，同时采用这种继任语言的方法，从而成为现有 C++ Plus 用户的一个引人注目的选择。我们中的几个人觉得，这实在太有趣了
to leave this way. This is something we need to explore. So we started building something that would fit into these. We're calling it the Carbon Language. Welcome to ADSB, the podcast, episode 88, recorded on July 25th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we talk about the exciting new announcement in the programming language world, Carbon. All right, so listener, we just started episode, I think it's 88. We're going to be recording
不能就这样搁置。这是我们需要探索的方向。于是我们开始构建能够契合这些要求的东西。我们称之为 Carbon 语言。欢迎收听 ADSB 播客第 88 期，录制于 2022 年 7 月 25 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天与我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）一起，我们来聊聊编程语言界令人兴奋的新公告——Carbon。好的，听众朋友们，我们刚开始录制第... 我觉得是第 88 期节目。我们今天要录制
two episodes today. This might just be a part one, part two. News to me. Because I'll be going to the West Coast, so we need to, what is today? Why are you going to the West Coast? Going to the West Coast. My sister, sister oh yeah my three sisters is flying back from ireland for the first time in uh years this is the sister that i've met i've only met one of the three sisters i know it's shocking to me too dear listener and so yeah my family is uh taking a weekend in whistler to whatever just hang out so bopping out there tell everybody
两期节目。这可能只分第一部分和第二部分。我刚知道这事。因为我要去西海岸，所以我们需要... 今天是几号？你为什么要去西海岸？去西海岸。我姐姐... 姐姐，哦对，我的三个姐姐从爱尔兰飞回来，这还是好几年来的头一回。这是我见过的那个姐姐，三个姐姐里我只见过一个。我知道，这对我也挺震撼的，亲爱的听众朋友。所以呢，我的家庭将在惠斯勒（Whistler）度过一个周末，随便聚聚什么的。所以我要去那边转转，代大家
i say hello i will i will um anyway so we're recording these in advance and we do apologize or at least i apologize i'm not sure if bryce apologizes as well we said that we were gonna record live from cpp north so today is the 25th and a... I'm going to say it was my fault, because I decided to leave CPP North a little bit early, because it was enough. It was enough. Yeah, Bryce, you were originally supposed to fly out this Sunday or Sunday? Yeah, so we would have had a Thursday to Sunday to see ducks. Was that really necessary? I just remembered you were recording an episode that was the squeaky ball the dog loves things that squeak and loves balls so i found the ball
向他们问好。我会的，我会的……不管怎样，我们是提前录制这些节目的，我们要道个歉，或者至少我道歉，我不确定布莱斯是不是也道歉。我们曾说会在 C++ 北方大会（CPP North）进行现场录制。所以今天是 25 号……我得说这是我的错，因为我决定稍微早一点离开 C++ 北方大会，因为够了。已经够了。是的，布莱斯，你原本应该是这个星期天还是哪个星期天飞走的？对，所以我们本可以有一个从星期四到星期天的行程来看鸭子。这真的有必要吗？我刚刚想起来你在录制一期节目，那是那个会发出吱吱声的球，狗狗最喜欢会发出吱吱声的东西和球，所以我找到了一个
that squeaks and uh now now i've made a tactical mistake because for the next for the next 30 minutes she's gonna think it's it's ball play time and that that that that i'm gonna throw the ball for her this has got to be this has to be agonizing for our listeners because our listeners want us to talk about two things one primarily and and you're not staying focused bryce and we got we got we got a hard stop here what do i what do our what do our listeners well so we were in the midst of apologizing uh not only did we not record while bryce was in toronto but we didn't record live that probably wouldn't have ended up happening just because of how crazy it ended up being we tried to get chandler karuth from google on the last day and we could have made it work but it
会发出吱吱声的球，然后……现在我犯了一个战术错误，因为在接下来的 30 分钟里，她会以为这是玩球时间，以为我会把球扔给她。这一定让我们的听众感到痛苦，因为我们的听众想听我们谈论两件事，其中一个是主要的，而你却没有保持专注，布莱斯，我们在这里有个硬性截止时间。我们的听众……我们的听众……好吧，我们正说到道歉……不仅我们在布莱斯在多伦多的时候没有录制，我们也没有进行现场录制，这可能本来也无法实现，只是因为后来的情况太疯狂了。我们在最后一天试图邀请谷歌的钱德勒·卡鲁斯（Chandler Carruth）上节目，我们本可以做到的，但
just he had a flight and dinner plans and we would have had to do it at lunch right before my talk anyways so the two things that they probably want to hear about is cpp north because we were both there and we've been talking about it for the last two or three months on and off and of course a large announcement that took place at cpp north in chandler crew's keynote what should we start with should we start with a cpp north recap or should we go straight to the big news and share thoughts? I think we should start with the big news because I think it will be the most timely
他有航班和晚宴安排，而且我们必须在我演讲前的午餐时间进行。无论如何，大家可能想听的两件事是 C++ 北方大会，因为我们都在现场，而且过去两三个月里我们一直在断断续续地讨论它；当然，还有在 C++ 北方大会上钱德勒·卡鲁斯的的主旨演讲中发布的重大公告。我们应该从哪里开始？我们是应该从 C++ 北方大会的回顾开始，还是直接切入重大新闻并分享想法？我认为我们应该从重大新闻开始，因为我觉得这是最合时宜的
for it to be something that goes out this week. Perfect. All right. So maybe part one of this episode 88 and 89, part one will be carbon, and part two will be, I don't know, afterthoughts, however it works out. All right. So, Bryce, you go ahead and recap the announcement that I'm sure, I mean, I'd be surprised if any of our listeners, actually, I mean, there's some outside of the C++ community that listen that might not.
能在本周发布的内容。太好了。好的。所以第 88 和 89 期的第一部分可能是 Carbon，第二部分可能是，我不知道，一些事后感想，看情况怎么安排吧。好的。那么，布莱斯，由你来回顾一下这个公告吧。我确信……我的意思是，如果我们的听众里有谁……实际上，我的意思是，有些 C++ 社区之外的人也在听，他们可能不知道。
This news went pretty far and wide. Yeah. So, um, well, so a group of, uh, of people, um, some of whom are from Google, some of whom are not from Google, um,
这个消息传播得很广、很远。是的。所以，嗯，有一群人，其中有一些来自谷歌，也有一些不来自谷歌，
have gotten together and have decided to work on creating a successor language to C plus plus. And what, what we mean by successor language is a language that has as one of its core tenets interoperability with the language that it succeeds. So it's meant to be something that you can incrementally adopt in an existing C++ project. So a lot of people who have looked at it have said, well, this looks quite similar to Rust.
他们聚到一起，决定致力于为 C++ 创建一门继任语言（successor language）。我们所说的继任语言，是指在其核心宗旨中，包含与它所继承的语言具有互操作性的语言。因此，它意味着你可以在现有的 C++ 项目中对其进行渐进式采用。所以很多看过它的人会说，嗯，这看起来跟 Rust 相当相似。
Isn't Rust the successor to C++? And it is true that Rust and C++ have a very similar target audience in that they're both systems programming languages. And it is true that there is some degree of Rust and C++ interoperability. But the difference with this new language, Carbon, is that for Carbon, interoperability is one of the key goals and priorities. And it's not one of the key founding goals and priorities of Rust. The key founding goal and priority of Rust was memory safety and also to be a more accessible systems programming language than C++. But this interoperability question was not one of these key goals. And I think there's many other interesting aspects to carbon but i think
难道 Rust 不是 C++ 的继任者吗？确实，Rust 和 C++ 有着非常相似的目标受众，因为它们都是系统编程语言。而且也确实存在一定程度的 Rust 与 C++ 的互操作性。但这种新语言 Carbon 的不同之处在于，对于 Carbon 而言，互操作性是其核心目标和优先级之一。而这并不是 Rust 最初的核心目标和优先级。Rust 最初的核心目标和优先级是内存安全，以及成为一门比 C++ 更易用的系统编程语言。但这并非互操作性问题。我认为 Carbon 还有许多其他有趣的方面，但我认为
the the this is really the defining aspect um and the aspect that will uh either lead to its success or lack of success um most you know there's i have a few people uh nvidia that have created programming languages that i work with, one of whom is Andre. What language for those that aren't in the know did he create or help create? He helped create the D programming language. And I don't recall if it's Andre or if it's one of my other colleagues who created a programming language. But I was told that for a new programming language to really succeed, it has to be 10x better than the existing programming languages on some dimension.
这确实是其决定性的方面，也是将决定其成功与否的方面……你知道的，我在英伟达（Nvidia）有几个同事创建过编程语言，其中一位是安德烈（Andre）。对于那些不太了解的人，他创建或协助创建了什么语言？他协助创建了 D 语言。我不记得是安德烈还是我的另一位同事创建了编程语言。但我听说，一门新的编程语言要真正取得成功，它必须在某些方面比现有的编程语言好上 10 倍。
Not like 10x better like in every way. There has to be some 10x better aspect to it. And I think that's absolutely true if it's a language that you need to like switch to like you have to be like i was programming in language x and now i'm programming in language y yeah that requires like an immediate rewrite Yeah. Now, for a successor language like Carbon or like TypeScript or like Kotlin, because the cost to adopt is much lower because of the interoperability focus, I believe that the bar for success is lower, that you do not need to be, you know, 10x better, that maybe you can just be, you know, 2x better in a bunch of small ways, or that you can, you know, clean up a lot of historical mistakes, that you can just make a whole bunch of smaller improvements that add up to being a much better language. Even though maybe no one of those small improvements would be sufficient to get somebody to buy into, I'm going to completely rewrite all of my software in this language.
不是说方方面面都好上 10 倍。它必须有某个方面要好上 10 倍。我认为，如果你必须进行切换的话，绝对需要这样——也就是说，你必须觉得：我以前是用 X 语言编程的，现在我要用 Y 语言编程。是的，那需要进行立即重写。是的。现在，对于像 Carbon、TypeScript 或 Kotlin 这样的继任语言来说，由于专注于互操作性，采用成本要低得多，我认为成功的门槛也更低。你不需要做到（比方说）好上 10 倍，也许你只需要在许多小地方好上 2 倍，或者你可以清理掉许多历史遗留错误，你可以做出大量较小的改进，累加起来使它成为一门好得多的语言。尽管也许这些小改进中的任何一个都不足以让某人买账，并决定“我要用这种语言完全重写我的所有软件”。
And that to me is really the interesting thing about Carbon, is that it promises an incremental path, an incremental adoption, and that it can be incrementally better, that it can still retain a lot of the priorities that we have for C++, like performance and portability, without being tied down by the legacy that C++ has to deal with. But this is actually, this is not the reason why I'm most excited about carbon. I think the interoperability is why I think most people would be most excited about carbon. But I am in the programming language evolution business.
对我来说，这正是 Carbon 最有趣的地方，它承诺了一条渐进式的路径、渐进式的采用，并且它可以做到渐进式的改进，它依然能够保留许多我们对 C++ 的期望，比如性能和可移植性，同时又不会被 C++ 必须应对的历史包袱所束缚。但实际上，这并不是我对 Carbon 最感兴奋的原因。我认为互操作性是大多数人最感兴奋的原因。但我从事的是编程语言演进业务。
And so the thing that's most attractive to me about carbon is its model for evolution and its process. And I think that carbon has a drastically better process than C++. And in fact, I would even go so far as to say that the carbon process is 10x better than the C++ evolution process. And I also think that that's probably true for a language like Rust or a language like Swift. These modern languages that, you know, largely use our modern collaborative tools like GitHub for, you know, decision making and change management and that use better stakeholder models where, you know, there's some sort of core team, but anybody can make contributions and the core team really just makes decisions among a set of options. I think that the difference in having an open model built on modern collaborative tools versus the rather dated ISO-based model that
所以 Carbon 最吸引我的地方在于它的演进模型和流程。我认为 Carbon 的流程比 C++ 好得多。事实上，我甚至可以这样说，Carbon 的流程比 C++ 的演进流程好上 10 倍。我也认为这对于像 Rust 或 Swift 这样的语言来说可能也是真的。这些现代语言（你知道的）在很大程度上使用我们现代的协作工具（如 GitHub）来进行决策和变更管理，并且它们使用更好的利益相关者模型（其中有某种核心团队，但任何人都可以做出贡献，而核心团队实际上只是在一组选项中做出决策）。我认为，拥有一个建立在现代协作工具基础之上的开放模型，与 C++ 所采用的那个
C++ has, that's really a game changer. And I think that means that Carbon will be able to involve and improve and adapt much better than C++ will be able to in the coming decades so just to be clear do you like as you mentioned the 10x thing in terms of process do you think that's a reason why at the end of the day carbon will be successful you're just mentioning it as sort of like yes i i believe that the reason that carbon and rust will be successful is because they have substantially better process because it does it doesn't matter if they're better languages than today. It doesn't matter if they're the right tool today. If you think 10, 20, 30 years down the road,
相当陈旧的基于 ISO 的模型相比，确实是一个颠覆性的改变。我认为这意味着在未来的几十年里，Carbon 能够比 C++ 更好地演进、改进和适应。所以明确一下，就像你提到的关于流程的 10 倍差距，你认为这是最终 Carbon 会成功的理由吗？你只是把它作为一种……是的，我相信 Carbon 和 Rust 会成功的原因是它们拥有实质上更好的流程，因为这与它们是否比当今的语言更好无关。这与它们现在是否是正确的工具无关。如果你考虑未来 10 年、20 年、30 年，
and if you think about all of the known ways in which languages will have to evolve, but also the unknown ways in which languages might have to evolve. I have far greater confidence in languages that have an agile, modern evolution process. And that doesn't mean that those languages can't, you know, interact with ISO. There are plenty of ways in which, if there was ever a need for a language like Rust to have an ISO standard in which that could happen. ISO commonly forms these relationships with other standards development organizations and has these fast track processes for other organizations that develop standards to turn their standard into an ISO standard as well.
以及如果你考虑所有已知的语言必须演进的方式，还有那些语言可能不得不演进的未知方式。我对那些拥有敏捷、现代演进流程的语言有着更大的信心。这并不意味着这些语言不能与 ISO 进行互动。如果有需要像 Rust 这样的语言拥有 ISO 标准的需求，有很多途径可以实现这一点。ISO 通常会与其他标准开发组织建立这种关系，并为其他开发标准的组织提供快速通道流程，将他们的标准也转化为 ISO 标准。
You could also imagine that the, you know, standards for something like rust or carbon could be developed outside of the ISO process and, you know, by some separate foundation, and then the results could be contributed to ISO. So these things are not mutually exclusive. I just think that using the ISO process to evolve a programming language is not the correct decision today. It was certainly the correct decision in the 90s for C++. It was definitely the correct decision for older languages like C and Fortran. And in particular, it was certainly much better to have ISOC than ANCIC, because ANCIC was developed solely by a U.S.-based standards development organization. And so its mandate was really very U.S.-focused. And ISO does provide a slightly, you know, broader view. But I think at the end of the day, given the collaboration tools that we have today, given
你也可以想象，像 Rust 或 Carbon 这类语言的标准可以在 ISO 流程之外制定，由某个独立的基金会完成，然后将结果贡献给 ISO。所以这些事情并不是互斥的。我只是认为，今天使用 ISO 流程来演进一门编程语言并不是正确的决定。这在 90 年代对于 C++ 来说绝对是正确的决定。这对于像 C 和 Fortran 这样较老的语言来说绝对是正确的决定。特别是，拥有 ISO C 绝对比拥有 ANSI C 要好得多，因为 ANSI C 完全是由一个美国本土的标准发展组织制定的。所以它的使命确实非常侧重于美国。而 ISO 确实提供了一个稍微（你知道的）更广阔的视角。但我认为归根结底，鉴于我们今天拥有的协作工具，鉴于
how software communities operate today, it's just not the right stakeholder model. And I do hope that we can perhaps fix that in the future for languages like C++ and Fortran. All right. So I will play the role of an amalgamation of the top questions that I have, because I've spent quite a bit of time and I'll link all of this stuff. There's the keynote from CPP North is that Chandler gave and made this announcement and is already online. So I'll link that, but also the hacker news, Reddit thread, a couple different articles. And so there's been, and in the comments of the keynote that's online now, there's been a ton of discussion, obviously. I think the Hacker News post for a brief time on the Tuesday that the announcement was made,
当今软件社区的运作方式，这根本不是正确的利益相关者模型。我确实希望我们将来能为 C++ 和 Fortran 这样的语言修复这一点。好的。那么我将扮演汇总我收集的主要问题的角色，因为我花了不少时间，我会把这些资料都链接上。C++ 北方大会上有钱德勒发表的主题演讲并发布了这个公告，目前已经在网上有了。所以我会把这个链接放上，还有 Hacker News、Reddit 帖子以及一些不同的文章。因此，在目前网上的主题演讲评论区里，显然有大量的讨论。我认为 Hacker News 帖子在发布公告的那个星期二的短暂时间内，
it hit number one, and there's hundreds of comments on the Reddit threads. There's been lots and lots of questions. I think you already asked probably the number one or answered already the number one question, which is why not just use Rust? A lot of people comment that the syntax looks similar, but you already talked about the interop story and how that is sort of the big delta between the two. And there's others, but that's sort of the, I think the response to that question. Probably the second most popular question that I observed or comment that I made was, why not just make C++ better?
它冲到了第一名，Reddit 帖子上有几百条评论。有非常非常多的问题。我想你可能已经问过或回答了头号问题，那就是为什么不直接用 Rust？很多人评论说语法看起来很相似，但你已经谈到了互操作性的情况，以及这如何成为两者之间的大分水岭。还有其他问题，但这就是对那个问题的回应。我观察到的或收到的评论中，大概第二受欢迎的问题是：为什么不直接把 C++ 变得更好？
Which was actually, I think, a question that the Carbon team during the Q&A got. And so I'll let you. I'll give the answer for the Carbon team that I don't think you would have gotten during the Q&A, which is the people involved with Carbon spent a decade plus trying to make C++ better. Yeah. Didn't work out. And it's not like they didn't try. It's not like somebody like Chandler did not spend a significant chunk of his career and time and effort trying to make C++ better. And actually, if you look through the history of C++, there have been many figures
这实际上也是 Carbon 团队在问答环节中被问到的一个问题。所以我就交给你了。我来给出 Carbon 团队的答案，我想你在问答环节中可能不会听到这个答案：参与 Carbon 的人花了一十多年时间试图让 C++ 变得更好。是的。没有成功。并不是说他们没有努力。并不是像钱德勒这样的人没有花掉他职业生涯中相当大的一部分时间和精力去试图让 C++ 变得更好。实际上，如果你回顾 C++ 的历史，有许多人物
who have tried to improve C++ through the committee and have then departed to make programming languages. Doug Greger, Dave Abrahams, two of the people behind Swift, they used to be deeply involved in C++, and they are prolific software engineers and programmers and programming language designers um so why and they love c++ of course so why did they are they no longer involved now dave is getting back into the c++ world these days, but not so much the committee, at least not that I've seen yet. Well, I don't want to speak for these folks. when we've had throughout the history of C++,
他们曾试图通过委员会来改进 C++，随后离开去创建编程语言。道格·格雷格（Doug Greger）、戴夫·亚伯拉罕（Dave Abrahams），Swift 背后的两个人，他们过去曾深度参与 C++，他们是多产的软件工程师、程序员和编程语言设计者。那么为什么……而且他们当然热爱 C++。那么为什么他们现在不再参与了呢？虽然戴夫最近又回到了 C++ 世界，但没有参与那么多委员会，至少我还没怎么看到。好吧，我不想替这些人说话。纵观 C++ 的历史，
not one, not two, but three or four times when large, significant contributors have decided that their efforts were not, that spending more time on ISO C++ was just not worth it, and that they decided they were going to go off and do something else. Now, this is a sort of a unique case, because this is a group of people who are not going off to build a programming language with a different set of goals and priorities. Well, I guess you could argue that Carbon does have a different set of goals and priorities to the sort of implicit goals and priorities
不是一次，不是两次，而是三到四次，大批重要的贡献者决定他们的努力不值得，在 ISO C++ 上花更多时间根本不值得，于是他们决定另起炉灶去做别的事情。现在，这是一种有点独特的情况，因为这是一群没有去构建一套具有不同目标和优先级的编程语言的人。好吧，你可能会争辩说，Carbon 确实有一套不同于 C++ 委员会那种隐含目标和优先级的
of the C++ committee. I don't know that we've really properly, formally adopted a set of goals and priorities. But this is the first time that a group of people have gone off to create a successor language for C++, not a different type of language. Like Swift is a different type of language. I would even argue that D is a different type of language. And Rust is a different type of language. Carbon explicitly aims to be a successor language to C++. Now, and I want to circle back to that question about why Carbon and not Rust.
目标和优先级。我不知道我们是否真正恰当地、正式地采纳了一套目标和优先级。但这确实是一群人第一次离开去为 C++ 创建一门继任语言，而不是一门不同类型的语言。就像 Swift 是一门不同类型的语言一样。我甚至可以说 D 语言是一门不同类型的语言。Rust 也是一门不同类型的语言。Carbon 明确旨在成为 C++ 的继任语言。现在，我想回到关于为什么选择 Carbon 而不是 Rust 的问题上。
And yes, interoperability is a big piece of it. But I also think that there's other differences in goals that are significant. Rust has memory safety as one of its key goals. That is not one of the key goals of Carbon. There's a hope that memory safety will be something that can be added to Carbon, but it's not one of the key goals and priorities. I think the focus on performance in carbon is a sort of unique goal among other you know, contemporary programming languages to it. And it's also a goal that I think is to some degree shared by C++. Or at least I think most people involved in the C++ evolution and most
是的，互操作性是很大的一部分。但我同时也认为，目标上的其他差异也很重要。Rust 将内存安全作为其核心目标之一。这不是 Carbon 的核心目标之一。人们希望内存安全可以成为未来添加到 Carbon 中的东西，但它并不是核心目标和优先级。我认为 Carbon 对性能的专注，在其他同代编程语言中是一种比较独特的目标。这也是一个我认为在某种程度上与 C++ 共享的目标。或者至少我认为大多数参与 C++ 演进的人以及大多数
C++ users feel that performance is a priority of C++. Now, the problem is when performance comes into conflict with stability and predictability. I think Carbon will not be afraid to make breaking changes when it needs to, and to weigh the cost of that breaking change and how tooling might help us adapt to that breaking change versus the benefit and performance. I'm not saying that carbon is going to make drastic, huge breaking changes for a you know, a 2% performance gain. I'm saying that if there's some reasonable breaking change that can lead to, you know, 2x, 3x performance in some way in carbon, that that's almost certainly something that I would
C++ 用户都认为性能是 C++ 的优先级。现在，问题在于当性能与稳定性和可预测性发生冲突时。我认为 Carbon 在需要时不会害怕做出破坏性的变更，并且会权衡破坏性变更的成本、工具将如何帮助我们适应这种破坏性变更，以及它所带来的性能收益。我并不是说 Carbon 会为了区区 2% 的性能提升而做出剧烈的、巨大的破坏性变更。我是说，如果在 Carbon 中存在某种合理的破坏性变更能够带来 2 倍、3 倍的性能提升，那么几乎可以肯定这是我
suspect carbon will pursue. Whereas in C++, when you have to pick between performance and stability, we pick stability more often than not. Yeah, and I'm sure a lot of our listeners know this, but there was a big discussion at the last in-person committee meeting before the pandemic started in Prague. And Corrington has a really good blog, which includes his personal thoughts on it. But it was a big discussion about ABI and whether or not the committee should take a stance on whether they want to break it or don't break it. And I actually, I think that that discussion could have been more productive because a large part of the framing of the argument
猜测 Carbon 会去追求的方向。而在 C++ 中，当你在性能和稳定性之间做出选择时，我们十有八九会选择稳定性。是的，我确信我们的许多听众都知道这一点，但在疫情爆发前在布拉格举行的最后一次委员会实体会议上，曾有过一次大型讨论。科林顿（Corrington）有一篇非常好的博客，其中包含了他的个人见解。但那是一场关于 ABI 的大型讨论，讨论委员会是否应该对是打破它还是不打破它表明立场。而我实际上认为，那场讨论本可以更富有成效，因为该论点的很大一部分框架
was about performance, that we should, you know, be willing to break the standard library ABI so that we can improve the performance of things like unordered map and things like unique putter. And that's a true argument, but I do not think that is by far the most compelling argument. I think we should be willing to break ABI so that we can
是围绕性能展开的——我们应该（你知道的）愿意破坏标准库 ABI，以便我们可以提升诸如 unordered_map 和 unique_ptr 之类东西的性能。这是一个真实的论点，但我认为这绝不是最引人注目的论点。我认为我们应该愿意打破 ABI，以便我们能够
make C++ easier to use. Like, forget performance for a minute here. We should be willing to break C++ ABI so that we can fix our mistakes, so that we can get rid of, you know, weird, confusing semantics that don't make sense to users. We should be willing to make breaking changes, not just ABI breaks, but breaking changes so that we can get rid of sharp edges and corner cases of C++. We should be willing to make breaking changes so that we can make C++ a safer language, so that we can remove pitfalls, so that we can make C++ a simpler language, so that we can make C++ a more teachable language. I think that if you made that argument, you would get far more of the committee on your side than if you made an argument solely about performance because this question of velocity and instability is not just one about performance.
让 C++ 更易于使用。先别管性能的事。我们应该愿意打破 C++ ABI，以便我们能够修复错误，从而摆脱那些对用户来说毫无意义的怪异、令人困惑的语义。我们应该愿意做出破坏性的变更——不仅仅是破坏 ABI，而是破坏性的变更——以便我们能够摆脱 C++ 的尖锐边缘和角落情况。我们应该愿意做出破坏性的变更，以便我们可以让 C++ 成为一门更安全的语言，从而消除隐患；以便我们可以让 C++ 成为一门更简单的语言，以便我们可以让 C++ 成为一门更易教的语言。我认为如果你提出这个论点，你会让委员会中更多的人站在你这边，而不是仅仅围绕性能提出论点，因为这种关于开发速度和稳定性的问题不仅仅关乎性能。
It affects the very nature of the language and the complexity and the usability of the language. And it saddens me that we did not have that conversation at Prague. Now, on the other hand, that one discussion was a culmination of many years of discussions. And I think many of the points that I just raised have been discussed over the years. were just framed around the question of performance and did not grasp or remember the full scope of what we sacrifice in the name of stability. Yeah. Yeah.
它影响着语言的本质、语言的复杂性和可用性。让我感到难过的是，我们在布拉格没有进行那样的对话。另一方面，那场讨论是多年讨论的结晶。我认为我刚才提出的许多观点在过去几年中都被讨论过，只是它们被框定在了性能问题周围，而没有抓住或记住我们为了稳定性而做出牺牲的全貌。Yeah. Yeah.
One of the most, well, I'm not sure if it's the most attractive thing, but just like carbon is going to look so much nicer because they're going to get the defaults right. Whereas, I mean, you'll start off writing. But carbon doesn't have to get the defaults right. If carbon gets the defaults wrong, carbon can fix the defaults. Like the C++, I suspect, got most of the defaults right at the time that we decided upon those defaults. I mean, that's the thing is a lot of the quote unquote defaults that like they're getting decided on if you're not making a decision
其中一个最……好吧，我不确定这算不算最有吸引力的地方，但就像 Carbon 看起来会好得多，因为它们能把默认设置搞对。然而，我的意思是，你一开始写……但 Carbon 并不需要一开始就把所有默认设置都搞对。如果 Carbon 的默认设置弄错了，Carbon 可以修复默认设置。就像我猜想的那样，C++ 在我们决定这些默认设置时，大部分默认设置都弄对了。我的意思是，问题在于，如果你没有对某些东西做出决策，很多所谓的默认设置
on it, right? Like if you're not taking into account some no discard attribute on a member function at the time, no one was thinking of it. So like implicitly, the default was that it's not no discard. And so in the future, when the design discussion comes up, it's like, oh, yeah, this would be a nice thing. But because you didn't, the default was already decided. So like I agree that probably when thinking about the defaults that were being thought about, they got them right. But unfortunately, like you can never predict all of the future behaviors that you're going to or design decisions that you're going to be making that. Unfortunately, you implicitly when you when you design something and you don't take into account like every possible flavor of something, it's's gonna you might get the default wrong but the point being is that like you know in c++ i start off writing a simple example of some function in a class and then like by the end of it if i turn clang tidy on there's like literally
就会被决定下来，对吧？比如，如果你当时没有考虑到成员函数上的 no_discard 属性，当时没有人想到它。所以隐式地，默认情况就是它不是 no_discard。因此在未来，当设计讨论出现时，就会变成：“哦，是的，这会是个不错的功能。”但由于你之前没做，默认情况已经定下来了。所以我同意，当思考当时正在琢磨的默认设置时，他们大概弄对了。但不幸的是，你永远无法预测你将要做出或需要做出的所有未来行为或设计决策。不幸的是，当你设计某样东西却没有考虑到某种可能的风味时，你可能会把默认设置弄错。但关键在于，你知道的，在 C++ 中，我一开始写类中某个函数的简单示例，然后到最后，如果我打开 clang-tidy，那里就会有字面意义上的
no discard constexpr no accept con like there's so many things that it's like a christmas tree that you're hanging like little ornaments on by the end of it. It's like if it's a small function, it ends up looking so complicated when really it's just a bunch of defaults that unfortunately we didn't think about at the very beginning. And that is going to be super nice and something that Carbon really has going for it. imagine, because I've seen these examples at Google IO when they were introducing Kotlin, where you would take some Java code, and it would obviously it's a cherry picked example, but then they have this automatic converter that like takes all this boilerplate, and then converts it into like three lines or whatever. And you know that there's going to be some, you know, cherry picked C++ example that has all of these, you know, ornaments, if you will, and then it converts it into some carbon code, and it's going to look so much cleaner. Oh, yeah, definitely. And you
no_discard、constexpr、no_except、const……有那么多东西，到最后就像你挂上小饰品的圣诞树一样。如果它是一个小函数，最后看起来会变得如此复杂，而实际上它只是一堆不幸的是我们在最初没有考虑到的默认设置。这将会超级棒，也是 Carbon 确实具备的优势。想象一下，因为我在 Google I/O 上看过这些示例，当时他们在介绍 Kotlin，你拿一段 Java 代码，显然这是一个精心挑选的示例，但随后他们有了这个自动转换器，把所有这些样板代码拿走，然后把它转换成大约三行代码之类的东西。你知道肯定会有一些精挑细选的 C++ 示例，里面带着所有这些（如果你愿意的话）饰品，然后它被转换成一些 Carbon 代码，看起来会干净得多。哦，对，绝对的。你
know, this, this reminds me of something from Sean Parent's keynote, which bookended the conference, and his keynote was called The Tragedy of C++. And I loved it because it was a redux of my favorite Sean Parent talk ever. And I think one of the best conference talks I've ever seen. It was probably the best conference talk I've ever seen. Perhaps the first time I saw Hana give like a full length talk, or the first time that I saw you give a talk, compete there. But it's definitely in one of the top three. And that was his 2012 C++ Now keynote, where he talks about performance and, you know,
知道吗，这让我想起了肖恩·帕伦特（Sean Parent）的主题演讲中的内容，那场演讲为会议作了收尾，他的演讲名叫《C++ 的悲剧》（The Tragedy of C++）。我很喜欢它，因为它是我最喜欢的肖恩·帕伦特演讲的重制版。我认为那是我看过的最好的会议演讲之一。它可能是我看过的最好的会议演讲。可能是我第一次看哈娜（Hana）做一个完整的演讲，或者是我第一次看你在那里同台竞技。但它绝对排在前三名之内。那是他在 2012 年 C++ Now 大会上的主题演讲，他在演讲中谈到了性能，以及
how you get performance out of a chip, and talks about heterogeneous programming, which in 2012 is pretty radical. And then he shows these amazing demos of, I don't remember which Adobe product running on an iPad with rendering this huge image and just very prescient in his predictions of where we needed to be, you know, 10 years later. And yeah, his talk, I was very excited to see him give sort of a talk that called back to that talk. He showed a lot of slides from that 2012 talk in his keynote. I think, obviously, from the title, The Tragedy of C++, Sean feels that we've perhaps not come as far as we would have liked.
你如何从芯片中榨取性能，并谈到了异构编程——这在 2012 年可以说是相当激进的。然后他展示了一些精彩的演示，我记不清是运行在 iPad 上的哪个 Adobe 产品，它在渲染这个巨大的图像，他对我们（你知道的）10 年后需要达到什么位置的预测非常有先见之明。是的，他的演讲……我很高兴看到他发表了一个呼应那个演讲的演讲。他在主题演讲中展示了许多来自 2012 年演讲的幻灯片。我想，显而易见，从《C++ 的悲剧》这个标题来看，肖恩觉得我们可能没有走到我们希望的那么远。
I think in some ways we have, and perhaps those have not yet become visible to him. Maybe those are things that you and I see because we're committee members and we see those features going out the door right now. Whereas Sean, who's not as actively involved in the committee these days, but is a C++ user, he's out in the field. He's writing actual applications. And these cool new tools that we're putting into the next standard and the standard after that, you know, they're not available to him yet. And I think that's one way in which we on the committee often lose a bit of perspective that we standardize a thing and we're all excited about it. Well, even after we put it in the standard and ship the standard, there's still a pretty long tail for it to get out to users. But anyways, in Sean's keynote, he referenced, I think, a talk by Alex Stepanov where he talked about the complexity of std pair. And he showed how many lines of code were needed to implement
我认为在某些方面我们确实做到了，也许这些变化对他来说还不可见。也许这些是你和我能看到的东西，因为我们是委员会成员，我们正看着这些特性此刻发布。而肖恩现在虽然不像过去那样积极参与委员会，但他是一个 C++ 用户，他在一线。他在编写实际的应用程序。而我们正在放入下一个标准以及之后的标准中的这些炫酷的新工具，（你知道的）对他来说还不可用。我认为这是我们在委员会中经常失去一些视角的一个方面：我们标准化了一个东西，我们都为此感到兴奋。好吧，即使在我们将其放入标准并发布标准之后，要将其推广到用户手中仍然有一个相当漫长的尾声。无论如何，在肖恩的主题演讲中，他引用了亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫（Alex Stepanov）的一场演讲，他在演讲中谈到了 std::pair 的复杂性。他展示了在 C++98 中实现
std pair in c++ 98 and i think it was like 150 and alex stepanov 62 62 and alex stepanov was just distraught that something so simple would require 62 lines of code and then in c++ 11 it was what how many lines of code i think i think that was the one that was like 150. Yeah, and then in C++17, it was how many? It was like 500 or something. It like exploded. Yeah, exactly. And it's the same in terms of the size of the C++ standard text,
std::pair 需要多少行代码，我想大概是 150 行，而亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫是 62 行。62 行。亚历山大·斯捷潘诺夫简直痛苦万分，这么简单的事情竟然需要 62 行代码。然后在 C++11 中是多少行代码？我想那大概就是 150 行的那次吧。是的，然后在 C++17 中是多少？大概是 500 行左右。直接爆炸了。是的，完全如此。C++ 标准文本的篇幅也是如此，
which has gone up from a few hundred pages to, I think it's near 3,000 maybe now? No, I think it's just under 2,000. It's 1,800 something. Ah, okay. Although maybe C++23 is. Yeah, I think C++23 is probably over 2,000 or it will be once we're done with it. This morning we had the last C++ plenary of the C++23 design cycle where we shipped out the C++23 committee draft and we had 62 motions and we voted in a lot of stuff.
它从几百页增加到……我想现在大概接近 3,000 页了吧？不，我觉得不到 2,000 页。大概 1,800 多页。啊，好吧。不过也许 C++23 达到了。是的，我想 C++23 可能超过 2,000 页了，或者在我们完成它之后就会超过。今天早上我们召开了 C++23 设计周期的最后一次 C++ 全体会议，我们在会上发布了 C++23 委员会草案，我们有 62 项动议，并且投票通过了很多东西。
And that was easily 200 pages of things would be my guess. MD-SPAN got in. Congratulations. MD-SPAN is the reason I joined the committee back in 2015. And this is an excellent demonstration of the point of how long of a tail it is to get things standardized. I joined the committee in 2015 with the goal of getting MD-SPAN into the standard. It is 2022 and it is now in. And it will not be widely available until 2026 probably. So it will have taken me 10 years to accomplish this one relatively simple thing.
我猜那轻松就有 200 页的内容。MD-SPAN 被收录进去了。恭喜。MD-SPAN 是我早在 2015 年加入委员会的原因。这完美地展示了将事物标准化的周期有多长这一观点。我于 2015 年加入委员会，目标是将 MD-SPAN 纳人标准。现在是 2022 年，它终于进去了。直到 2026 年左右，它可能都不会被广泛使用。所以我花了 10 年时间才完成这件相对简单的事情。
Yep. Yeah. Probably wouldn't have taken as long in a non-ISO model. I do not think it would have taken as long in a non-ISO model. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。是的。在非 ISO 模型中可能不会花这么长时间。我认为在非 ISO 模型中不会花这么长时间。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。